[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week beef I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from the donut project in Manhattan's
West Village a place that's known for
drawing headlines and wraparound crowds
for unique creations today we make
history is the donut project unveiled
the first ever hot ones donut but enough
goofing off let's make an awkward
transition to the kitchen and figure out
what the hell reading for breakfast
let's go hi I'm Leslie polizzotto and we
are here at the donut project in the
West Village so what we wanted to do is
a hot ones donut is we wanted to kind of
do a riff off of the chicken wing and we
use the hot one sauce in our glaze and
we as little confectioners sugar as
possible so that the spiciness of the
sauce will come through our dough is
actually not very sweet it can eat it on
its own it's it's very similar to just
like bread we dip the donut in the glaze
and then we have a blue cheese crumble
and then we have fried crispy chicken
skin on top so it's a chicken wing donut
we think people are going to think this
doughnut is very unique and strange and
probably it's probably going to be a
dare to actually eat it but if you close
your eyes you would think you were
eating a chicken wing where does the hot
ones donut rank on the spectrum is that
one of the crazier things you guys have
ever made is it par for the course where
is it sit on that scale probably nine
point seven five whoa so high I'm the
crazy high on the crazy it's got chicken
skin which is very out there it's got
blue cheese on it and then the hot one
sauce so it's pretty much crazy this is
a big moment it is the unboxing of the
hot ones Donuts oh wow
it's the hot ones donut time to give it
a try love how it has some give I can
tell it's fresh it's fresh to the touch
it is so good it's a little hotter than
you expect it to be I have had this hot
one sauce I'm basically everything ever
made on wings on tacos on breakfast
burritos whatever this is amazing and I
know what you're thinking on the other
side of that screen oh my god I want to
bite to I want to bite you the good news
is that you can just in time for
national chicken wing day the donut
projects first leaf fees we're doing the
hot ones donut see down below for
details get yourself a hot ones donut
you'll be happy that you did Leslie
thank you so much for making a young
man's dream come true
[Music]